George Floyd's brother is speaking
publicly for the first time
Terrence Floyd was among hundreds who
gathered for a vigil yesterday near the
place in Minneapolis where his brother
was killed during an encounter with
police Jamie yuccas is there for us now
Jamie good morning what did Floyd's
brother have to say about the violence
over this past week
well Tony he says he knows it's not what
his brother would have wanted he's tired
of seeing destruction like this but it
seems last night protestors took his
brother's words to heart as the
demonstrations were far more peaceful in
contrast to the chaos and destruction
Minneapolis protesters took part
overnight in a peaceful sit-in near the
place police pinned down George Floyd
[Music]
earlier speakers called for justice and
more arrests Floyd's brother Terrence
import for the looting to stop in
Minneapolis and across the country a
newly released autopsy commissioned by
the Floyd family says the cause of death
was asphyxiation from compression to the
neck and back it differs from the
official autopsy which says Floyd died
from a heart attack while being
restrained both labeled the death a
homicide cuz everything is in the dark
and now it's coming to the light Nino
sky lives in Minneapolis and attended
the vigil with his young niece he hopes
the protest will help give her a better
future are you hoping there's change
that comes from my brother's change
because you know there's been so much
hope hopefully this actually you know
puts cops in a position but if you
approach somebody now you have to
hesitate my approach you don't just go
in and think you can do whatever you
want and you're gonna get away with it
Terrence Floyd says there's at least one
alternative to the destruction no sky
told me the government needs to change
up the system if it wants to stop this
cycle of violence when I asked what that
would look like he had a simple three
word response safe free and peace
Anthony Jamie thank you